good morning Hank it's fooling around it
good morning Hank you just got said
hello to you by lots of nerdfighters and
also
so Hank I'm in New York City still on
tour for Will Grayson Will Grayson I
don't want to say thank you to all the
nerdfighters who have come out and also
particularly to all the nerdfighters who
have gotten me t-shirts I got this shirt
this shirt this one features my rapping
name J scribble and I got this one it's
a nice shirt I appreciate it it's a
little small
oh Henry and I got this shirt which has
asked me about conjoined twins which as
it turns out is one of my areas of
expertise Hank I don't know if you know
this but I have one of the largest
collections of books about conjoined
twins ever assembled in fact I have more
books about conjoined twins than there
are conjoined twins and yes that
includes if you count them separately
which you should which is one of the
many interesting things you can learn
from conjoined twins literature so
obviously writers love to write about
conjoined twins because it's very
convenient metaphor right like thinking
about conjoined twin Anna sleeves all
kind of questions about identity and
separation and where does one human
being end and another human being begin
and like no matter how hard you try you
can never abandon your family because no
matter what you do they're right freakin
there attached to your hip or in our
case Hank attached to the camcorder but
I think the really fascinating thing
about conjoined twins is ultimately not
that metaphor although it is interesting
but the question of whether and why we
should separate conjoined twins there's
this great book one of us by Alice
Drager in which she argues that our
obsession with separating conjoined
twins whenever it's medically feasible
and even sometimes when it's very
medically dangerous is a reflection
about discomfort with unusual anatomies
I think you might note that the most
famous conjoined twins in American
history were Chang and Eng two guys from
Thailand the original Siamese twins they
became very successful circus performers
and were eventually able to buy a
plantation and they both got married to
separate ladies and had kids I don't
know how it worked maybe one of them was
like dude are you done yet also one of
them was an alcoholic and the other
wasn't even though they had the same
blood
anyway even in the 19th century Chang
and Eng could have possibly been
separated by a surgeon but they didn't
want to be separated because in addition
to all the disadvantages of conjoined us
there are a number of advantages for
instance your Anatomy allows you to go
from being poor in Thailand to being
rich in America also you're never alone
there's always someone in bed with you
to warm up your feet now admittedly
there's also always someone with cold
feet who's rubbing them against you and
there are a bunch of other disadvantages
to the anatomy of conjoined admit but
there are also a bunch of disadvantages
to regular human anatomy like we can't
fly and it's impossible for human beings
with regular anatomies to benchpress
more than 80 pounds that's not
impossible well are you saying that I
have a weird Anatomy so Drakkar ends up
arguing that even if it's medically easy
to separate conjoined twins at birth you
should wait until they're old enough to
decide whether they want to do it
themselves before you do and that the
problem isn't with conjoined twins but
is instead with us for failing to accept
unusual anatomies anyway Hank this has
been much on my mind lately because when
you become a parent you become obsessed
with the idea of normal like the other
day I called the pediatrician I said
Henry seems to be peeing a lot is that
normal pretty much with babies as far as
I can tell everything is either normal
or it's scary and I think it's very
helpful to think about the extreme end
of that and conjoined twins even though
that's very uncommon phenomenon because
it's a good reminder in a world that
only celebrates normal that just because
something isn't normal doesn't mean that
it's bad or scary so might not have
talked of question of the day which I
don't think is easy or simple to answer
should we separate conjoined twins at
birth Hank don't forget to be awesome
I'll see you on Wednesday